hi I have a fantastic piece of news for
you today my completely new website
dedicated to making you a fantastic
language learner you want to know the
ultimate truth about learning foreign
languages well that is the case just
bear with me a few minutes and you will
find it out in this new web site you can
make two things that will make your
language learning happen that will
change it forever here and now first you
can take coaching sessions with me I'm a
language coach and I've been working as
such for the last eight years with
students all across the globe
I feel honored I feel privileged to be
able to help other people learn foreign
languages which is a fantastic adventure
and second you can take a look at my
blog the Polya dream which has been
integrated in the platform and you can
take a look at actionable steps
actionable techniques methods secrets
that have been revealing and will reveal
to make your language learning better
faster and more efficient i'm
Mukhopadhyay law I'm the founder of
lucan apparel calm and I'm going to show
you right now what this website is about
let's take a tour
so here we are this is the main page of
the website and as you can see here you
have five simple sections home services
FAQ about and blog and let's start with
the main page here is a picture of me
smiling that was taken in Poznan in 2014
where i gave a workshop if you scroll
down a little bit you will see a video
of me explaining and talking briefly
about my language a coaching story
what which led what led me to become a
language coach and then you have here a
quote of me my name is Luka Morello and
I can help you learn any foreign
language if you have any problems in
terms of language learning or in
insecurities if you scroll down you can
see a few testimonials from by my
wonderful student Sergio learning
Italian kuleana learning Russian and Joe
learning Italian German and Spanish with
me then you have my assets and coaching
experience I have learned 13 languages
over the last two decades which give me
a lot of experience in terms of self
learning but I've also coached hundreds
of students all around the world which
has given me further experience and
understanding of how my language
learning techniques can apply and adapt
to other people and I work hard to give
them the confidence to learn and speak
because they think that the
psychological aspects of language
learning is extremely important and all
this is based on science and research
I've been I've been carrying out four
ears you can see here my most recent
blog post will talk about the blog in a
little bit and then also if you want to
more specifically memorize and you
become very better speak with native
like pronunciation and intonation use
your target language with confidence and
many other things as you can see here
you can join my mailing list and get my
free 3 video series which is an
important way to get started let's let's
go up again
and let's go to the about about me page
and here as you can see I briefly talked
about my mission which is to give you
the tools and the know-how to learn any
language as efficiently as possible
and obviously in guide you along the way
I firmly believe that what is lacking
nowadays is not resources it is more
than know how how to do things and here
is the brief description of the
languages that I speak here is a quote
that summarizes my language learning
philosophy languages cannot be taught
they can only be learned I firmly
believe in this so you can learn any
language with a little bit of my help
but you can't I can't teach you the
language you have to learn it by
yourself here is a brief description of
my language journey and what led me to
become the person I am today here's
another video describing a little bit my
my daily life and how I use languages on
a daily basis and and then here
scrolling down you have you still can
join my newsletter remember that if you
want to contact me directly and ask me a
question you can go at the bottom of the
page and push the contact me button
going up and let's go to services this
is the page that is at the core of this
website and if you scroll down you will
see about my coaching lessons some
information you can choose between one
lesson a single lesson or a five lesson
package or a 10 lesson a package and
here you have a list of features that
make up the lesson or the packages then
more specifically I have come up with
four special packages let's start with
getting started in any language so this
is a package for people who have never
learned a foreign language before maybe
they try to school but failed and this
is specifically for people who want to
learn a language from scratch by
themselves and/or people who have tried
to learn language
but want to try new methodologies then
you have the from intermediate to
advanced package which is for people who
have an intermediate level but they feel
like they got stuck and they want to
reach a very high level improving your
speaking skills so this is a very common
request from students that I have that's
the reason why this package is here so
people want to know how to speak better
they already speak the language but they
want to know how to be more confident
how to use words more properly properly
and how to be a better communicator and
then last but not least pronunciation
training which is a specific training of
how to understand and have a very solid
grasp of the phonetic fabric of any any
language and here you can book your
lessons once again you have an overview
of how to book the lessons 1 session 5
sessions or 10 sessions I want to stress
the fact that unfortunately I'm just one
person so this is a special offer also
in terms of price and we have slots that
we will open periodically so if you have
the chance just of grabbing one or five
or package of five or ten just grab it
grab it now and let's go to fa Q's here
so this is a list of questions that I've
been compiling this is these are very
common questions so it was relatively
easy for me to compile these questions
these questions hopefully this list is
very thorough but once again if you have
a specific question that doesn't appear
here on the list you can always go to
the bottom of the page and push the
contact me button and just send me a
specific question and/or request last
but not least the blog so this is a no
review of the blog which contains all
the information that was in the previous
blog which is the pollak adream and this
blog offers you free advice a free in
free
insight into language learning language
learning philosophy and very practical
tips on how to learn languages but most
of all this blog and this very same
website gives you the inspiration to
learn any foreign language and this will
be a revolution for you
why have I created all this it's because
I feel like in the language learning
world something is missing and that
something is the know-how you might have
noticed that you have a lot of resources
but sometimes you don't know how to use
them you might have a lot of people to
talk to on the Internet in real life but
you don't know what to say and how to
say to improve your language learning
potential you might have a lot of words
but you lack the confidence and the
courage to use that as a human being you
have an amazing potential and my mission
is to make that potential unfold and
that's the ultimate truth of language
learning nobody can teach you a language
you have to learn it by yourself with
some invaluable help from experts so if
you want you have the chance right here
and right now to change your language
learning world don't miss it for
exclusive content and my three video
series that I share with subscribers
please head to Lucca Lipari on low calm
and subscribe obviously to the
newsletter
I truly hope to see you there soon bye
you